citizens the reject Nation it is time
for us to catch up cuz we are super late
to this for the final trailer for Five
Nights at Freddy's John is everything
okay with you it's great I'm ready for
them to shine more light on this how is
your security job going it is great
nothing spooky has happened yet and it
definitely will not that's what I like
to hear guys you best believe we will be
reacting to this movie can't wait to see
it I've been loving the promo footage so
far let's see what this final look is
all
[Music]
about
spooky screens surveillance cameras the
game oh my
God dang oh Noy oh no
guys there's animatronic in
there
oh no chica no hell yeah oh my God yes
they are providing the punch on this one
piece of cake
really oh
no this one feels a lot more
scuzzy
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
them
yet met
who the cast love it Showtime Bonnie
foxy Bon
Freddy star performer here
oh back in the 80s best decade some kids
went missing what is this it's why the
place shut
down the police holy they never
found the
kid what the heck
damn this one is like a true horror
trailer
yeah
no spooky ghost
children possessing giant robots yes
tell me how to stop them you can never
stop them it's too
late he's coming Freddy is coming one
two Freddy's coming for you
whoa that trailer zoomed by yeah Dam
that looks Wicked that was gripping yeah
I went by so quick I know thought we
were just getting started yeah right oh
more trailer yeah this one definitely
provided more of that uh horror punch to
it like the other ones uh had a bit more
of that dread atmospheric tease and this
was really honing in on what I can only
describe as the fun and game side of the
movie where it is is going to be like a
lot more of the gore gag Fest and it
just felt a lot more grimy and
unsettling I thought this was a really
Punchy trailer I'm glad though because
like the the last one kind of revealed
decent amount of the story and this one
even less story but clearer on the story
especially on the possession of the fact
that the they they pretty much removed
the mystery surrounding what these
animatronics are now which is one of my
criticisms with the marketing is ah I
didn't really need to reveal that I know
that if you dive into the lore play the
games you already know that you'll
eventually get there exactly you already
you'll already get there and I I don't
feel like they needed to unveil that
they could have kept some of that
clouded in mystery uh because they did
pretty much just shine a light directly
on it that kids possessing animat truck
ghosts of dead kids yeah it's it's all
there but this one had had that truly
spooky vibe to it and in a day and age
where we get a lot of horror not a lot
of horror movies often feel like
something you would watch at Halloween
time even even even like the Halloween
ends
especially even those Halloween movies
don't feel like a Halloween film you
know a trick- or treat kind of festive
experience and this feels like the kind
of movie that would be a blast to watch
around Halloween time and it's with it
being Universal you the other thing I'm
looking forward to too is that uh you
know that they're gearing up nothing
this year but I bet next year at
Halloween Horror Nights they're going to
be having a Five Nights at Freddy's maze
you know 100% And I cannot wait for that
they might just make it like a year-long
attraction depending on how big of a hit
this movie ends up being I know I well
in all the I mean like it's already such
a huge monolith in terms of games and
merch and just like the culture in
general so like I could see them doing
something like that at Universal Studios
I won't say much about this oh I wish I
could even tease a little bit but I
don't want to get anyone in
trouble um I met some
someone somewhere okay that a thing and
this guy was a little drunk and he had
show and I thank God I actually don't
remember his name but I remember his I
remember his position but I don't
remember his um but he he showed me
something he was working on for Five
Nights at Freddy's oh um and and it was
awesome oh good good good I'm happy to
hear that's all it'll be a thing we can
all
experience and it was it was really cool
so yeah no I thought I thought this was
a great trailer and I'm glad it's the
final one because I we need not see
anymore yeah and it's been a funny year
for for horror movies in general because
I feel like I've heard so many people
say like oh man this has such like a
funh house Halloween time Vibe and yet
it's out in April or it's out in you
know August and you're like why not
release these things around Halloween so
I am happy that we have something like
this to look forward to and I think
probably why my
Theory as to why they put the whole dead
children thing in the trailer is
probably because they want to further
separate themselves from Wily's
Wonderland and things like that because
I feel like there are aspects of a
trailer like this that are just going to
look similar like in general and I think
that's something that takes the games
like a little while to get to but uh I
think it's it's enough of like a kind of
mish mash of different horror ideas and
like you said you don't know the story
but you know at least people have tried
to break in here and now they need
somebody to watch the space so that
nobody vandalizes it or whatever and
that's going to lead Josh Hutcherson in
here and so like there is you know
certainly like a patented similarity
this is going to happen because of
animatronic kids you know arcade but uh
yeah this has like a really I'm still
waiting to get a sense for what the
actual tone of like the plot following
Josh Hutcherson will be like what the
actual experience of watching the movie
will be but in terms of the promise of
the horror as you said the promise of
the set pieces and the promise of
something that but it's that one shot
where that person is being like you know
menaced by these turning gears and
things and like that continually reminds
me of Saw and so I do feel like one
benefit or one sort of neat thing about
this is you can Collide yeah the freaky
uncanny Creepy Pasta ghostliness of it
with some maybe not like balls to the
walls but with some actual kind of
horror Centric action or or dare I say
Carnage and uh do we I forget is this
ridar I feel like
it has to be kind of disappointed if it
isn't yeah so I feel like that will kind
of pack the punch and I'm glad that for
this they leaned mostly into the horror
flavors and just again the aesthetic is
so much of the appeal anyway because we
all have that Association of like
Chuck-E-Cheese and stuff as kids and you
have yeah your appropriate sprinkling of
here's some 88s mockup footage um but
yeah like pound for pound this looks
like it'll be a fun but also kind of you
know slightly nasty kind of horror
Halloween roller coaster or something
like that well what they also the movie
itself I think really needs to do is
convey what makes Freddy stand out
different from everyone else and that
way it's not just a variety of
animatronics just look different but I
really want to see what makes them
different and can you provide a
different personality that's the that's
one of the qualities of this movie that
I'm a tad hesitant on is
it can feel repetitive or it could feel
a lot of the same just some of them look
different without them actually feeling
or moving or have a personality that
actually feels different and is just
they need to be distinguishable more
than just how they appear on the surface
and that's a really especially when
you're doing a trailer that's
highlighting who all these personalities
are and what they're named and whatnot
that's a a very important quality that I
think this movie has to possess no pun
intendent but all right guys what did
you think about this trailer are you
excited for Five Nights at Freddy's
thank you so much for being here uh
thank you for being patient with us we
get this out let's talk to you guys
[Music]
soon